Voyager 2 hat eine äußerst mysteriöse Magnetwand
zwischen unserem Sonnensystem und dem Interstellaren
Raum entdeckt.
Die Sonde ist am 20.8.1977 gestartet und erst
letztes Jahr hat sie den Interstellaren Raum
erreicht.
Aber es bleiben auch noch viele Rätsel ungelöst!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen und vielen Dank für Euren
coolen Themenvorschlag, der über unsere Telegram-Community
kam.
Vielen Dank für den Vorschlag.
Das ist wirklich irre und niemand hätte sich
DAS damals träumen lassen.
Doch mittlerweile sind die beiden Voyager-Sonden
also Voyager 1 und 2 schon fast 42 Jahre im
All unterwegs.
Beide sind jetzt in einem Bereich des Weltalls
unterwegs, in dem noch niemals zuvor ein Objekt
geflogen ist, das von Menschen erschaffen
wurde. 2012 war es eine echte Premiere, als
Voyager 1 die sogenannte Heliopause passierte,
die oft auch als “Grenze unseres Sonnensystems”
bezeichnet wird.
Denn dahinter beginnt dann laut Definition
der interstellare Raum.
Auch “New Horizons” ist derzeit auf dem
Weg zur Grenze unseres Sonnensystems.
Doch diese zu Passieren - das haben bisher
nur die beiden Voyager-Sonden geschafft.
Denn dafür müssen nicht nur gigantische
Entfernungen überwunden werden, sondern auch
die Gravitationskraft der Sonne.
Doch am 5.
November des vergangenen Jahres (2018) war
es dann soweit: “Voyager 2” hatte die
Heliosphäre verlassen und war in den interstellaren
Raum eingetaucht.
Dazu twittert die NASA ein Jahr später, also
Anfang des Monats (November 2019)
“The fantastic voyage continues!
One year ago this week, Voyager 2 joined me
in interstellar space.
Today, five papers published detailing my
twin's findings in the region just beyond
the bubble created by our Sun.”
NASA Voyager @NASAVoyager 4.
Nov.2019
Fünf Forschungsteams also waren daran beteiligt,
die Messdaten auszuwerten und haben diese
jetzt präsentiert.
Und die ganze Untersuchung bringt erstaunliche
Erkenntnisse mit sich!
Denn den Fachleuten ist es nun möglich, die
Daten von Voyager 1 mit den Messungen ihrer
Schwestern-Sonde zu vergleichen.
Die Studien verraten viele Details, wie genau
der Abschied von Voyager 2 aus unserem Sonnensystem
vonstatten ging.
Dabei hatte die NASA-Sonde wohl eine 1,5 Astronomische
Einheiten breite Grenzregion, die Heliopause,
passiert.
Eine astronomische Einheit ist der Abstand
zwischen der Erde und der Sonne.
Hier staut sich der Sonnenwind und wird langsamer.
Doch die Daten von Voyager 2 unterscheiden
sich von den Beobachtungen ihrer Schwesternsonde,
die im Sommer 2012 in den interstellaren Raum
eingetreten war.
Damals konnte die NASA-Sonde in bestimmten
Bereichen ein mysteriöses Phänomen beobachten.
Interstellares Material drang dabei in die
Heliosphäre ein.
Nach der Passage durch die Heliopause gab
es extreme Turbulenzen - vermutlich ausgelöst
durch Interaktionen zwischen Sonnenwind und
interstellarem Medium.
Diese Turbulenzen konnten mit Hilfe der Messungen
von Voyager 2 aber nicht festgestellt werden.
Dazu Leonard Burlaga von der NASA: “Demnach
war die von Voyager 2 beobachtete Heliopause
stabil und dünn, im Gegensatz zur instabilen
und dickeren Heliopause, die Voyager 1 durchquerte“.
Die Ursache für diesen Unterschied steht
noch nicht mit letzter Sicherheit fest.
Die Forschenden vermuten aber, dass dies möglicherweise
mit der Aktivität der Sonne zu tun haben
könnte.
Denn die Heliopause wurde von Voyager 1 während
eines Minimums im solaren Aktivitätszyklus
passiert - bei Voyager 2 fand die Passage
nahe am Maximum des Zyklus statt.
Sprich die Dicke der Heliopause hängt von
der Aktivität der Sonne ab.
Eine gibt aber eine weitere Erkenntnis, die
die beiden Sonden ermöglicht haben: Demnach
scheint die Heliosphäre also die Shäre um
unser Sonnensystem - zumindest auf einer Seite
- eine symmetrische Kugelform aufzuweisen.
Diese Rückschlüsse ziehen die Forschungsteams
aus der Tatsache, dass beide Raumsonden die
Grenze der Heliosphäre in fast gleicher Distanz
passiert haben.
Bei Voyager 1 waren es es etwa 121 Astronomische
Einheiten; bei Voyager 2 rund 119.
Klar ist: Beide Sonden haben dieselbe Halbkugel
der Heliosphäre durchquert - und diese schräg
in Flugrichtung unseres Sonnensystems verlassen.
Damit wird aber auch eine Annahme widerlegt,
von der Fachleute lange Zeit ausgingen: Nämlich,
dass der Sonnenwind immer weiter abnimmt,
je weiter man in den interstellaren Raum kommt.
Stattdessen zeigen Voyager 1 und Voyager 2,
dass es dort eine ausgeprägte Grenze gibt.
Also quasi einen scharfen Übergang zum lokalen
interstellaren Medium.
Super spannend auch folgendes Ergebnis: Im
lokalen interstellaren Medium liegen die Temperaturen
bei -ACHTUNG - 30.000 bis 50.000 Kelvin.
Und das übertrifft noch einmal alle Erwartungen
der Fachleute, die bislang von 15.000 bis
30.000 Kelvin ausgegangen waren.
Möglicherweise manövriert die Heliosphäre
eine Art Bugwelle vor sich her durch das interstellare
Medium.
Doch die Chance stehen schlecht, dass die
beiden Sonden diese noch erreichen und genauer
analysieren können.
Denn bis dahin wird ihnen vermutlich die Energie
ausgehen.
Fachleute gehen davon aus, dass die radioaktiven
Batterien der Sonden noch etwa fünf Jahren
reichen werden.
Dazu der Planeten-Forscher Edward Stone: “Als
die beiden "Voyagers" gestartet wurden, war
das Weltraumzeitalter erst 20 Jahre alt.
Niemand hat erwartet, dass sie 40 Jahre halten
würden.
Eine weitere, wirklich super spannende Entdeckung
gelang den Forschenden außerdem durch die
Auswertung der Daten von Voyager 2.
Denn die Sonde ist offensichtlich auf eine
Art Magnetwand getroffen.
Die Rede ist von einer Magnet-Barriere, die
die kosmische Strahlung abschirmt.
Dazu heißt es in einer der fünf Studien:
“Die Existenz einer solchen Barriere wurde
zwar vorhergesagt, aber erst jetzt haben wir
sie nachgewiesen.
Das Magnetfeld in dieser Barriere war stärker
als jedes zuvor in der Helio-Hülle gemessene
Magnetfeld.“
Voyager 1 hatte diese magnetische “Wand”
damals nicht entdeckt, die wohl das Eindringen
energiereicher, elektrisch geladener Teilchen
aus dem interstellaren Raum in die Heliosphäre
reduziert.
Die Daten klären also viele bisher unbeantwortete
Fragen und beweisen auf ein Neues, dass die
Grenzregion unseres Sonnensystems überaus
komplex ist und es sich um ein hochdynamisches
System handelt.
Doch natürlich bleiben immer noch viele Rätsel
ungelöst… Leben auf Mars schon längst
entdeckt?
- das hat die Viking-Sonde der Nasa schon
1976 gefunden?
Astro comics tv,, anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren!